[Musik]
Ich verfolgte einen kleinen protestierenden Emmanuel
Macron, der einen Hahn loslassen würde
Hamilton hat mein Leben eingeschrieben, Tell Kevin
wochen antik und eric houde wollen nicht
die eines Defranzisierungs-Sternschnuppens
Nitrate West unterstützt danke
vielen dank ich bin klein aufgewachsen
Dorf in Nordfrankreich post
industriell zum Feiern oder in den Jahren
70 und 80
die meisten Männer im Dorf
Arbeit in der Fabrik sage ich das
Männer, weil oft Frauen
hatte nicht die möglichkeit bzw. nicht die
Recht, noch weniger zu arbeiten
meine kindheit mein vater wollte meine nicht
mutter arbeitet sie wollte es mein vater
sagte nein, die Rolle einer Frau ist zu
Bleib zu Hause und ich bin dort aufgewachsen
dieses Milieu mich, in dem ich geboren wurde
90er, also eine Zeit, in der
fast alle Fabriken in der Region
geschlossen war geschlossen und die meisten
Menschen um mich herum leben in der
Prekarität in Ausgrenzung in der
Armut
und es ist in diesem Zusammenhang ein wenig
dass ich mit diesem Hintergrund aufgewachsen bin
totalen Ausschluss und das wollte ich machen
diese Welt dort die Angelegenheit meines Schreibens
das Thema meiner Bücher, weil
Ich hatte den Eindruck, dass Sevilla diese
Körper dieser Personen seine Reden war
war völlig von der Rede ausgeschlossen
jedenfalls weitgehend literarisch
ein Dutzend Kälber sollen sogar lächeln
und Yukon Current Kendrick, der Tisch marc
und ging nach bruay jeder hat angst
als mit der Normandie
der Dummy, dass das Klischee und Mineralien
ja, denn in der Tat, wenn Sie es wollen
dass ich für Menschen kämpfe
sprach für Leute, die von unten kamen
Leute, es bedeutet nicht unbedingt zu tun
Das Lob dieser Leute soll es nicht sein
sagen, es bedeutet nicht, gut zu sein oder
schlecht zu diesen Leuten zu sein ist
so fair wie möglich und daher ich wann
Ich sprach über diese beliebte Umgebung
Erwähnenswert über dieses schlechte Umfeld
Es ist sehr wichtig, dass es für mich ist
über Homophobie sprechen
Rassismus auch das Dorf in dem
Ich war erwachsen, also bin ich erwachsen geworden
Dorf, in dem die Leute mehr als gewählt haben
50 % für die nationale Front
wie ich dir meiner Mutter gesagt habe, würden wir es tun
arbeitete gern, aber mein Vater wollte nicht
Nein, sie wollte Make-up tragen
aber mein Vater sagte ihm das Make-up
es ist für [ __ ] und du kannst nicht
tragen und so gab es dieses extreme
Gewalt gegen Frauen
auf Minderheiten auf Schwule auf
Fremde und so für mich zu sprechen
all das bedeutet nicht im Geringsten
viele beliebte Klassen, das heißt
im Gegenteil sogar noch mehr
Personen in dieser Kategorie 1 Klassen
beliebt und hatte ich schon immer
den Eindruck, den sie hatten und
Philosophie und Literatur für diese Angelegenheit
eine Form der Mystifikationstradition
und Klassenmythisierung
beliebt, die sogar unter gefunden werden kann
große schriftsteller wie pasolini mögen
Jean Genet, der eine Art war
Weise glauben zu machen, dass für
Kampf um die beliebten Klassen für
es war notwendig, um ihr Leben zu kämpfen
loben
als ob das Leben dort besser wäre
wenn das Leben dort authentischer wäre
Gold für mich diese Rede der Mythisierung
und Mystifikation
es ist ein Diskurs, der unsichtbar macht
viele Leute darin
Mitte ist in der Tat, was von einem Ganzen spricht
kleinen Teil dieser Umgebung, das heißt
eher Männer als Frauen eher
Heterosexuelle statt Schwule
die weißen tasten eher die schwarzen
Arbeiter, die das Lumpenproletariat ist
so endlich, was wir angerufen haben
Arbeiterklassen schienen sich zu erheben
eher ein sehr kleiner Teil von
beliebte Klassen und ich wollte aufnehmen
noch mehr noch mehr Menschen
in in dieser Kategorie und zusätzlich zu
das, und es ist sehr wichtig, wenn ich das sage
denke das in dieser Mystifikation
Es gab eine Art Hinweis
der meritokratischen Ideologie video logis
eigentlich rechte Ideologie
konservativ, was darin bestehen würde zu sagen
Um für Menschen zu kämpfen, muss man
zeigen, dass er es verdient hat
es muss gezeigt werden, dass sie es letztendlich sind
gute Leute, die Menschen sind
authentisch und ich bin es, was ich will
Sagen wir, wir kämpfen für Menschen, die
leiden, egal ob er es verdient hat oder
Es spielt keine Rolle, ob es gut ist
kämpft gegen objektive Bedingungen, die
hat sich nicht bei einem Sozialfonds angemeldet
Mentalität
Hintergründe Yohan Mathis Beton als 5
Dinar PS-Anteil
wenn du willst, meinte die gie
kurz vor der Mitte, in der ich habe
aufgewachsen und ist ein Umfeld, in dem
männliche Werte
die gleiche männliche Besessenheit war die
Wert der wichtigste Saal der
am mächtigsten am präskriptivsten
Nennen Sie es normativ und in der Tat den Mann
Pierre Bourdieu erklärt das sehr gut
wenn er sagt, dass wir im Grunde alles wegnehmen
die populären Klassen werden der beraubt
Zugang zu Geld ökonomischem Kapital
wir nehmen den Zugang zu Schulkapital weg
Schule, zu der ihnen der Zugang verweigert wird
Kultur
Zugang zur Welt meines Vaters zum Beispiel
Er ist noch nie in seinem Leben gereist
verlassen frankreich seines lebens und damit die
das Einzige, was wir diesen Personen überlassen
und für nicht sehr lange ist es ihr
Körper und deshalb sagt Pierre Bourdieu er
sollte nicht überrascht sein, wenn von diesem
Zeit diese Personen der Klassen
beliebt teilweise nicht jeder
Außerdem gibt es immer Ausnahmen
wie überall, aber einige davon
Klasse, die eine Ideologie des Körpers aufbaut
und daher von Männlichkeit und daher von
Stärke, denn das ist alles, was sie haben
und alles getan haben alles getan
unser Leben könnte, wenn Sie es tun
Literatur muss man selbst machen
Glauben Sie ein wenig dieser Literatur
das ist dir am wichtigsten
Energie geben, es zu tun, wenn
Sie sind ein Journalist, den Sie müssen
um Sie glauben zu machen, dass Journalismus
aber was ist wichtiger für die
Demokratie und für die Welt und das tun wir
all dies bauen wir eine ganze Ideologie auf
von dem, was wir haben
und wie diese Leute mögen Leute
man kann
wie die Leute wie meine Mutter wie die
Menschen, mit denen ich aufgewachsen bin, aber
hatte nur das für sie
ihre Körper, wir sollten uns nicht wundern, wenn es sie gibt
hatte diese Ideologie des Ben des Körpers von
die Kraft der Männlichkeit, die hatte
Gewaltwirkung gegen Frauen
gegen LGBT-Menschen und so ist es
das System ist verantwortlich
von diesem meinem Spiel gebe ich alle Ausreden
Soziologie zu meinem Vater, wenn mein Vater
sagte mir, ich schäme mich für dich, weil du
Du warst eine [ __ ], dann war ich er
Früher habe ich es gehasst, aber jetzt sehe ich das
es ist ein System, das seine Karriere hervorbringt
für zwei ist intakt, aber dieser um 10
Milliarden, die ermutigen könnten
Pariser an der Furia verbindet Intellektuelle
Männer und Steuerbord bekomme ich
Galerie der Mittelstraße besonders besonders
was ist in der bar von angeklagt
vereinte nationen nachts im osten glaube ich
Flow sagte ja, wenn du Spiel I willst
sprechen Sie ein wenig darüber, dass damit fertig ist
Wortwahl und Geschichte der Gewalt
was ich versuchen wollte zu zeigen
Es sind diese Freunde, die ich eigentlich nicht hatte
dem sozialen Determinismus entgangen, aber
im Gegenteil, ich war entschlossener
sozial als andere, weil
Leute meiner Familie mein Bruder mein Vater mein
Schwester meine Mutter
hatte Klassendeterminismus
d.h. beliebte Klassen
Zugehörigkeit zu den beliebten Klassen und
wir alle wissen, dass wenn Sie zu a gehören
Wort ein beliebtes Umfeld, das Sie haben
gute Verbleibschancen in einem Umfeld
beliebt alle figuren der
Die soziale Reproduktion zeigt es, aber in
mehr von diesem Monat Sozialurteil
im Gegensatz zu meinem Vater im Gegensatz
meine Schwester im Gegensatz zu meinem Bruder
Ich hatte ein sexuelles Urteil, das l ist
Homosexualität ist eigentlich diese beiden
Urteile zusammen waren inkonsistent
und um meiner Geburt zu helfen, gab es a
Form der Inkompatibilität, die in war
soziologische Tatsache also persönlich also
vertraut mit meiner Familie seit meinem Vater
war jemand, der gelernt hatte zu sagen
dass Homosexualität das Schlimmste war
Dinge, als ich ein Kind war mein Vater
sagte, du musst die [ __ ] töten, die du musst
Nehmen Sie sie, Sie müssen begeistert sein und sind
als Homosexuelle bekannt waren
meine sehr junge Sexualität war ich alle
Fortsetzung aus dem Tritt mit meiner
Familie ist in der Tat hatte ich keine andere
Wahl als zu fliehen und das ist was
ich sage in das eindhoven und 10 in
ende mit eddy hübsches gesicht, wer das ist
Während meiner gesamten Kindheit habe ich es versucht
mich anzupassen versuchte ich zu sein
normal versuche ich was das hieß
Normalität von 2,2 entsprechen
Männlichkeitsnormen in meinem Umfeld
die wiederum eine Ursache haben
wir haben es kurz vorher erwähnt und dann ich
gescheitert und deshalb bin ich gegangen
Ich verließ aber, aber als ich war
Kind, wenn du willst, ich wollte
Mein Vater hör auf, sich für mich zu schämen
Ich wollte nicht James Baldwin Simone sein
um mir zu geben, was ich wollte
es war, dass mein Vater aufhörte, sich zu senken
Augen, wenn ich spreche, weil er
dachte, ich wäre zu feminin, weil
dass er dachte, dass ich aber wenn du
möchte diese Beziehung gerne beenden
das der Unmöglichkeit der Unmöglichkeit spricht
mit meinem Vater oder mit meiner Mutter sie
gehört zu einem ganzen soziologischen System
was bestimmte Personen ausmacht
zur Flucht aus ihrer Umgebung getrieben
was bedeutet, es ist eine Frage
sehr wichtige Politik, weil es
bedeutet, dass wenn ich frei wurde
aber dass ich nicht frei geboren wurde
dann bedeutet das, dass es eine Marge von gibt
Manöver ist eine politische Möglichkeit
Aktion was macht das aus
jemand kann laufen, weil ich ich ich
Ich wollte nicht sagen, dass ich wollte
nicht sagen, ich wollte nicht schreiben, ich bin
anders geboren, siehst du
Billy Elliot Mythos irgendeine Art von Mythos
von julien sorel in rot und schwarz
von stendhal, in dem Schicksale von Einzelpersonen
außergewöhnliche geboren in einer Umgebung, wo
andere sind nicht außergewöhnlich oder dazwischen
zwei Rosen mitten im Schlamm und ich
Ich wollte zeigen, dass es nicht so war
überhaupt das passierte, aber das an
im Gegenteil ich war frei geworden ich hatte
war dazu verdammt, fast frei zu sein
Trotz mir fast gegen mich und deshalb
wenn ich geworden bin, bedeutet das, dass es gibt
ein Prozess des Werdens ist was
dass es eine mögliche politische Aktion gibt
wie machen wir andere menschen
werden die Ziegen, wie wir tun
damit andere Menschen Wirbel werden
bergen das war es am ende auch
Frage, die ich durch die stellen wollte
Erzählung, aber kostenlos, es ist ein Casting
olympic kleynhoff in paris sage ich dir
nicht alles wird alles schrecklich gewesen sein
die liste gegen luzenac
Im Grunde hat es keinen intuitiven Höhepunkt
genau das, was sie uns nicht verkaufen
macht unregelmäßig Elsass
ja das heißt, dass ich da bin
Dinge, die in meiner Kindheit waren
undenkbar und unmöglich in dem Maße
wo unsere Weltanschauung war
voreingenommen durch die in der Stelle 1 enthaltene
Welt durch den Ort, an dem wir
in der Welt unsere Situation gefunden
in der Welt
Ich erinnere mich, als ich war
Kind in dem Dorf, in dem ich habe
erwachsen
mein Vater dachte, dass der Besitzer von
Das Lebensmittelgeschäft im Dorf war groß
bürgerlich, dass sie ein sehr war
reich usw.
und ich erinnere mich, dass meine Mutter sagte, ich solle helfen
llp die Steuer auf großes Vermögen dann
dass es tatsächlich jemand war, der hatte
einer, der fast im selben war
prekäre wirtschaftliche Verhältnisse, die
uns, aber einfach wie sie hatte
kein com und hatte keine Bosse
da sie einen anderen Status hatte
weil ihr das Lebensmittelgeschäft gehörte
Stadt
Wir hatten eine symbolische Wahrnehmung, dass
war ganz anders als diese Person
macht dieses Wissen aus
Teil der Welt, die sie machen
Problem der gesellschaftlichen Transformation
sehr kompliziert, denn wie willst du
Sie, dass Einzelpersonen möchten
verändere die Welt verändere die Welt
wenn sie nicht wissen, wo die echten sind
dominierend oder wo die Dominanz liegt
Vertrau mir, wenn ich glücklich bin und ich habe
zog nach paris
genau aus diesen üblichen Gründen
Kreuzritter eines zusätzlichen sexuellen Habitus
eines Klassenhabitus, über den ich erstaunt war
sehen, dass es dominant waren
immer dominanter als was
Reiche Leute hätte ich mir immer vorstellen können
reicher als ich dachte
es war, als wäre endlich die soziale Welt
und ist eigentlich endlos was da
erschien uns als der Große
bürgerlich von
das Alter, in dem die Vermieterin war
der Lebensmittelhändler plötzlich, als ich sah
das akademische Bürgertum
Pariser ihren Platz in der Hierarchie
gesellschaftlichen Wandel komplett und ich
verstand, dass sie tatsächlich mehr war
meinem Vater gesellschaftlich näher als
dominant und natürlich gibt es sie
differentielle Wahrnehmungen der Welt, die
machen es unmöglich, auf bestimmte zuzugreifen
eine bestimmte Art zu wissen
bestimmte Analysemodi
was eine sehr große Aufgabe ist
Tiefe
kucinich wurde getaggt oder fasziniertes Mädchen
Kapital der Jeep, aber wer nennt den
Wirtschaftsakteure mit Kapital
relationale und eine kulturelle Tabelle
Hauptstadt aminata mbengue ndiaye
Mechanismen müssen soziales Kapital sein
stufe eins mit christophe soumbou
Hauptsache Prestige tagsüber ist
der kapitalboom hat aber gewählt denke ich
dass sie zuerst von Kapital sprechen
wirtschaftlich, weil die Möglichkeit der
fördern die Möglichkeit, die zu leben
Überlebensmöglichkeiten sind Dinge
die wann absolut Priorität haben
du bist in prekarität
aber ich denke auch an Kapital
symbolisch
wir hören viele Leute sagen
und mir war es eine Rede, die
Ich habe in meiner Kindheit viel gehört
in den beliebten Klassen im Allgemeinen
das war niemand kümmert sich um uns
niemand spricht über uns
wir zählen für niemanden, der a war
Form der Besessenheit und damit beides
die zwei Aspekte kommen kommen vermischen sich
wollte, was sehr mächtig war
Ich mit den Gelbwesten
es war plötzlich die Entstehung von
die Entstehung der Wahrheit innerhalb der
politischen Bereich, und das ist sehr selten
Siehst du, plötzlich hörten wir
Leute, die sagten, ich kann nicht
meine Kinder ernähren
wir hören die Leute bald sagen
Es ist Weihnachten und ich weiß nicht wie
kaufe Geschenke für meine Kinder und
Leute, die sagten, meine Mutter ist
sterbe in einem 5 km entfernten Dorf und ich
kann es sich nicht leisten, sie zu besuchen und
kümmere dich um sie, während sie drin ist
Absterben
und wenn du mir diese Sätze willst diese
Sprache schien so viel mehr
wahr, dass alle Neusprech
technokratisch, der von erfunden worden war
die politische Welt während dieser letzten
Jahre, das heißt die Bemühungen
Verantwortung Schulden leben
zusammen und alle, die eigentlich waren
Reden, die die Welt von bedeckten
Diskurs, der die Realität und mich verdeckte
denke, dass in der Tat die Realität ist
sowas seltenes
Politik
und es ist nur in bewegungen
von Spannung in Bewegungen Sie
weiß, es ist sehr, sehr, sehr schöne Idee
dass ich wirklich gerne zitiert, weil es
sie ist so mächtig Titel dies
sehr schöne idee von gilles deleuze die
Philosoph, der uns sagte, Sie sehen
Mai 68 wurde viel gesagt, es sei der
Moment des Traums es war der Moment
Utopie, es war an der Zeit
die Fantasie einer anderen Welt ist in
Gilles Deleuze sagte aber nein
es war einfach die Realität
genau deshalb war es so
schön, es war ein Hauch von echt
Es waren Leute, die sagten, ich will
Leben Sie besser diese Leute, die mich ich sagten
will Liebe machen
Ich will Liebe machen, wo ich will
wen ich will wann ich will ich will haben
menschenwürdige Lebensbedingungen u
deleuze hatte etwas sehr gesehen
Ich sagte nur, es war ein Hauch
von echt und und danach suchen wir
unterstützt die Gelbwesten
heute und bei den Großen
soziale Bewegungen im Allgemeinen ist es
Endlich ein bisschen Realität, ein bisschen Wahrheit
im politischen Bereich, das macht es zum
die meiste Zeit und eine Welt von
Rauchschwindel Leugnung und Lügen
ging mit Lebensversicherung co we will
einen Test bestehen
oslo 10 allende square social forum
China ist ein Fan Arts Blätter groß
freie Strenge, die Reformursache essen
Warten Sie auf das Jahr, Mister John Crichton
von macron eines Präsidenten zine von
historische Familien der Tränenebene
Nadallift
dann diese Makrele in Wirklichkeit in Frankreich
in Frankreich manövriert unter dem
gleiche Form eines Präsidenten, der rechtfertigt
die n6 ein wald baggins ourique 1 lang
Datum der Welt bei den Nationalhelden der
Martha Wash Pasta Idaho City
General des Revolutions Mad Desire i
weiß nicht aber auf jeden fall in dem umfang
wo er etwas in ordnung bringt
von der Realität der Wahrheit ist es etwas
wichtige Sache, die passiert
bestehen
was ich mir ich kann nicht helfen
gerührt zu sein, wenn ich diese Bilder sehe I
Auch sie finden diese Bilder der Revolte
Ich finde sie
Ich finde sie schön, ich finde sie sehr
schön, weil sie sehr selten sind i
finde es sehr schön denn wenn was
passiert und das ist sehr selten
ist das zum ersten Mal seitdem
lang in frankreich
die dominanten hatten angst und das für mich
es ist etwas sehr Schönes
etwas sehr erfreuliches
Die Leute können sich nicht vorstellen, wie viel die
das Leben der populären Klassen das Leben von
ärmsten Menschen ist strukturiert durch
Armut durch Angst vor Angst welche
verursacht durch extreme Armut in
eine Brücke hinunter, wo Norwegen als Gustan
Ja, natürlich wird es eine Bewegung sein
sehr wichtig, was im Übrigen gewesen war
weniger bekannt - von den Medien weitergegeben
wahrscheinlich weil es so war
waren nicht-weiße Menschen
Es waren Schwarze und Araber
die immer als weniger angesehen werden
Französisch als die anderen und wer spricht durch
ein ganzes System ein ganzes System
Medienpolitik und wer waren
weniger publiziert, aber ich verstehe
genau zu einem Bindeglied zwischen den Revolten
von 2005 in den Vororten und der
Gelbwestenbewegung
heute ist was passiert in
in beiden Fällen ist es dasselbe
Es ist so, wie ich sagte, wir ergeben uns
weiß nicht, wie viel Leben
der professionellsten Menschen
arm ist durch Angst strukturiert
Angst vor Pässen nährt die Angst vor Schritten
zahlt seine Miete
die Angst, sich nicht versorgen zu können
braucht seine Kinder die Angst zu verlieren
sein Haus hat Angst, seinen Job zu verlieren
prekär mich all meine Kindheit lévy das
Ich beschreibe in meinen Büchern von Anfang an
bis zu dem, der meinen Vater getötet hat
Leben der Angst ist Leben der Angst
dauerhaft und wenn Sie etwas wollen
etwas so starkes für mich zu sehen
das plötzlich dann leider das
hat nicht lange gedauert aber alles
Plötzlich bekamen die herrschenden Klassen Angst
bekam Angst wegen seiner Bewegungen
leider hat es nicht gehalten
eine lange Zeit, aber sie wussten in ihrem
Körper für einige Augenblicke
was es war dieser Zustand fast
Ontologie der nach 6h Angst wer wer
bildet dein ganzes Wesen, dein ganzes Wesen
Existenz
und das ist etwas bewegendes
Im Inneren kommt eine Art von uns aus der Gerechtigkeit
als zu wissen, dass die anderen es wussten
ein wenig was es auch ist ja es ist ein
so eine gelbe Weste
Adeline Québec in der Hand, das heißt das
sie tragen Forderungen nach Gleichberechtigung
soziale Ansprüche von Wuala
Gehaltserhöhung
des Sozialschutzes so ist es a
Bewegung, die objektiv in ihr ist
Wesen einer progressiven Bewegung
linke Bewegungen
nach der Frage, die sehr ist
wichtig sind die Formulare, die können
Nehmen Sie diesen Schritt, es gibt viele
Wege zu sagen, es gibt viele Wege
zu sagen ich leide und wie sagt man ich
litt dieses College hören sagen ich
leidet unter Migranten und
Frauenrechte wohin gehen sie
sagen, ich leide unter Prekarität
des Klassensystems und Emmanuel Macron
Ich möchte, dass er das zweite sagt, was
wählen Sie die zweite Option seit
das erste ist eine Lüge
aber sehen Sie mich, es ist etwas
dass ich auch das persönlich bin
lebte in meiner Kindheit viel mit
Legenden meiner Familie, die oft
zögerte zwischen der Abstimmung für die Linke und
für die extreme Rechte ist das etwas
nämlich, dass sie fast kommen
nie in den dominierenden Klassen oder
in der Bourgeoisie, wo das Volk wählt
entweder eher rechtsextrem rechts
entweder eher links extrem links am
gutes Zentrum, aber Leute, die
zwischen links und extrem schwanken
Gesetz
es ist etwas, das oft sehr ist
markiert in den am meisten dominierten Kreisen
in den am meisten ausgeschlossenen Umgebungen, weil
dass genau es eine Art von gibt
suche zwei die mit uns darüber reden würden
Tatsache, dass sie mit uns sprechen würden, wer sein wird
hier, um uns zu verteidigen
ja und so saas etc ich denke es ist
sehr wichtig wenn wenn der link gewesen wäre
präsenter stärker
wenn die Linke weiter darüber geredet hätte
beliebte Klassen der Armut
Prekarität
was sie in großem Maße hat, hat in großem Maße aufgehört
hinterließ im Laufe der Jahre seine sieben Brüder
80er und 90er sprechen immer mehr die Sprache
Sprache der Technokratie des Lebens
zusammen für das gemeinsame Wohl vielleicht
Die Leute hätten weniger dafür gestimmt
für die nationale Front und für die Extreme
Recht im Allgemeinen in der Welt und daher
yam da ist die frage und das ist es auch
dass ich versuche, durch meine zu tun
Bücher ist, wie man einen Raum schafft
innerhalb dessen Menschen können
sagen, ich leide, wenn die Linke nicht produziert
kein Raum, in dem die
dominanter kann sagen, ich leide
und wird sich anderen zuwenden
Optionen, die wir nicht wollen
ekelerregend eklig und und
bestenfalls erschreckend
aber didier eribon in showzeiten der
Galerie weil nach und nach und
Exklusive Links zum Signieren
Links zu sein bedeutet für mich zu kämpfen
zur Reduzierung von Gewalt in der
Welt
das war's für mich so gegen alle
Formen der Gewalt Klassengewalt
Homophobie männliche Dominanz
das ist wirklich die Definition für mich
Nummer eins auf der Linken ist dieser Kampf
gegen die gegen die gewalt aber aber
aber genau das bedeutet, dass das Wort
links ist ein Wort, das vollständig sein muss
jedes Mal neu definieren
um genau zu versuchen, die meisten einzubeziehen
mögliche Formen von Gewalt einzubeziehen
die meisten zwei Städte die meisten Körper
die meisten Individuen und ich, das ist was
Ich versuche auch, mit zu tun
der meinen Vater getötet hat, ist auch de de
Ändere die Sprache der Linken ein wenig
ich wann ich angefangen habe zu schreiben wann
Ich fing an, über Klassen zu schreiben
beliebt fühlte ich mich wie
eine ganze Abteilung der Bücher über die
beliebte Klassen sprechen über Klassen
beliebt, wie wir in der gesprochen haben
50er als hätte es keine gegeben
Schwulenbewegung, als hätten sie keine
eine feministische Bewegung, als ob sie
hatte keine rassistische Bewegung
und als wäre die Zeit wie eingefroren
das und so glaube ich fühlte ich mich a
sehr wichtiges Bedürfnis nach einer Sprache
radikal zeitgenössisch auf die
Klassen und ich denke zum Beispiel das
heute passiert eine neue Sprache von
Klassen geht weitgehend durch die
Männlichkeit und das sage ich wenn
in dem du mein Vater bist, erkläre ich
dass ich erkläre, dass mein Vater in seinem
Kindheit, um seine Idee zu bauen
männliche Identität
er musste das Schulsystem weiter ablehnen
so schnell wie möglich, weil das
erschien als etwas von zwei
feminin von feminin, sich dem zu unterwerfen
Schuldisziplin zum Lehrer so
inmitten meines Vaters in seinem
kindheit sei ein echter mann sei ein echter
Mann, das bedeutete, von der Schule geschmissen zu werden
stoppte das jüngste Schulsystem
möglich und haben daher kein Diplom
und mit Straßenbahnen unterstützt werden
hart arbeiten
schlecht bezahlt etc und davon erzähle ich in a
Buch, was Enteignung daraus macht
wirtschaftliche Armut einfach
meinem Vater ist es größtenteils zu verdanken
männliche Dominanz und das, wenn Sie
Kampf gegen die männliche Vorherrschaft
Sie kämpfen auch gegen die Fortpflanzung
Soziales und Ungleichheiten
und hier ist es ein Beispiel unter
andere aber aber ich denke
das ist heute ein Bedürfnis
Radikal ist dringend im Einklang mit
pierre bourdieu und andere neu erfinden
die einzige sprache der klassen auch sehr
spröde
Nein, es ist vorbei, ich brauche mehr, ich weiß
nein die nummer kenne ich nicht
Ich kenne diese Zahlen nicht, was ich
kann dir sagen das ist heute mein
Vater, und das ist das Thema meines letzten
Buch mein Vater mit 50 ist er sehr
jung findet er es schwierig zu sprechen, er zu gehen
hat Atembeschwerden er braucht a
Maschine am Abend, damit zu atmen
sein Herz arbeitet, er wird operiert
ständig voller Pathologien
anders und es ist jemand, der nicht hat
niemand ist jemand, der keinen hat
große Pathologie
schwierig wie Leukämie oder Krebs
wie auch immer der Zustand seines Körpers ist
Zerstörung dieses Körpers ist es aufgrund der
Tatsache, dass er ein Mann war, der war
Arbeiter bis 35 Jahre 35 Jahre Gewicht
traf ihn in der Fabrik
den Rücken zerquetscht hat mein Vater wie voll
anderer Vater, wenn ich sage, mein Vater ich
Wenn ich auch über deinen Vater spreche, spreche ich von a
Kollektivvater mit 35 war er
mehrere Jahre gelähmt u
Danach genau wie im Film
von daniel blake the 2 ken loach who
Sein Name ist - Daniel Blake
mein Vater wurde vom Staat schikaniert
um jeden Preis wieder an den Arbeitsplatz zurückkehren
Kosten und wir sagten ihm, er solle Sie zurückgeben
auf Arbeit
trotz sinn crash trotz
Ihrer Gesundheit zerstört oder entweder Sie sind
Nehmen Sie die Sozialleistungen weg, die Sie haben
und so ist es entweder du gehst zurück zum
Arbeit und du wirst sterben, weil deine
Gesundheit zerstört und dass die Arbeit die
Zerstöre noch mehr oder dich
nimmt weg von der Sozialhilfe und Sie
sterben, weil Sie nicht mehr haben
Geld und so, wie ich immer sage
in frankreich bietet das system zweierlei
für die arbeitenden Klassen ist es zu sterben oder
sterben hier entweder Sie gehen zurück zu den
arbeiten um jeden Preis, auch wenn Sie
haben Sie Ihren Rücken schleifen, auch wenn Sie das haben
health grind entweder wir nehmen dir alles weg
nimmt dir das Geld weg und ich auch
Erkenne seine Zahlen im Leben nicht
Menschen um mich herum und diese Zahlen
sind Lügen für mich, ich weiß es nicht
nicht wichtig
diese tapferen irna erstattung sein
eine ziemlich virulente politische Partei in
Das palästinensische Frankreich hat es geschafft
design lass uns finden was liegt
françoise martin nash durchschlagend
chirac sarkozy holland oder die zeitschrift n
10 wer heißt oder pedro mit dem flugzeug und
wer macht estos nice to einfach cramant
zeigt einfach heinzmann nicht im fitnessstudio
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass es das gibt
verantwortliche Personen wer
haben eine Kraft, die andere nicht haben
zum Beispiel
Angela Merkel, die sie als Gastgeberin ausgewählt hat
eine Million Migranten
in deutschland aber emmanuel macron hat es
nicht getan, es ist einer der wenigen Menschen
wer hätte das in frankreich machen können wer
hätte sagen können und wegen ihm und
Menschen, die heute im Sterben liegen
Mittelmeer gibt es Menschen, die sterben
in den Alpen gibt es Menschen, die
Migranten und Migrantinnen, die sterben
in den Bergen und dass es einen gibt
Verantwortung, die mir das immens ist
die ich in meinem Buch zeigen wollte
es ist für mich paradoxerweise, wer getötet hat
Mein Vater ist kein Buch, das mehr ist
Politik als andere als meine beiden
andere Bücher, weil ich wollte
zeigen, wie für jemanden
Wie mein Vater ist Politik eine
intime Geschichte und das für meinen Vater a
Sarkozys Entscheidung oder eine Entscheidung von
Macron ist so intim wie er
Der erste Kuss ist so intim wie der
Das erste Mal, dass er Liebe gemacht hat, ist
so intim wie seine Beziehung zu
ihr Sohn, weil ich mich sehr erinnere
obwohl in meiner Kindheit, als sarkozy
beschlossen, genau den Unterricht zu erzwingen
beliebt seine Arbeit, um an die zurückzukehren
arbeiten unabhängig von ihrer Gesundheit
ungeachtet der Tatsache, dass mein Vater hatte
hatte einen Unfall in der Fabrik sie
konnte nicht mehr gehen als zuvor
Rückenschmerzen, die seinen Rücken knirschen ließen
Ich erinnere mich sehr persönlich
das plötzlich wegen dieser Reform
dieser Transformation des Systems
die Verwaltung rief meinen Vater alle an
die Tage belästigen sie, indem sie mir dabei helfen
Du musst wieder arbeiten, du musst
Geh zurück zur Arbeit, du musst zurück
bei der Arbeit und so war es für meinen Vater
es war etwas sehr intimes und
So ist es für mich, es ist der Test
Nein, diese Leute, diese Entscheidungen, die sie haben
nimm es ist ein Teil davon ist ein Teil davon
ihres Körpers ist ihre Geschichte
Körper und und Sie sehen, ich denke, es ist
sehr wichtig, dies zu sagen, weil dies
was sehr seltsam ist, ist das wann
Ich veröffentlichte Geschichte der Gewalt und
mit Tiermaul gemacht werden, wo i
sprach über die Welt meiner Kindheit, wo ich
sprach über die Arbeiterklassen, wo ich
sprach über Homophobie Rassismus
männliche Dominanz in meiner Kindheit
und versuchen herauszufinden, warum
so war es
Es gab viele Leute in den Medien
in der politikwelt bin ich und du
versuche sie zu entschuldigen, indem du es versuchst
zu ihren Kopien jemanden verstehen, der
Sag dreckige [ __ ] zu jemand anderem oder
sagen sie jemandem auf Arabisch
es ist jemand, der verantwortlich ist
kann die Verantwortung nicht abziehen
ist sehr seltsam, wenn ich gepostet habe
der meinen Vater getötet hat, wo ich über die spreche
Macrons Gewalt
sarkozy plötzlich die gleichen Leute
in dem
gleichen Medien und politischen Raum
sagte ah nein, aber immer noch Macron
eingenommen in einem Sarkozy-System eingenommen wird
in einem System gibt es so etwas tatsächlich
ein soziologisches Entschuldigungssystem
System der soziologischen Argumentation, dass
funktioniert nur für denjenigen, der es ist
für die Dominanten sehen Sie, dass wir bezahlen
sehr starke Tanga-Hintergründe
Emmanuel Macron wird am Montag veröffentlicht
abc Familie seine Position des Wortes nicht nicht a
verdient diese Makrele, die nur das hat, was sie hat
tun, aber die Fans der Inschriften
ist, dass wir von einem freundlichen ist sprechen
globalisierte globale optische PV und
alizee modernisieren ricciardo körperbau
transnet
ja, aber sie hat sie und ich
Ich glaube genau, dass der Begriff der
Determinismus und die ganze Arbeit von
Pierre Bourdieu und dann vor Einbruch der Dunkelheit
rosa luxemburg karl marx und andere
sind Werke, die alles herausfordern
fall, der serain zum se einlädt
radikal überprüfen und
tief über das Konzept von
Verantwortung und ich, darauf zurückzukommen
was du vorhin gesagt hast glaube ich
genau das je mehr du hast
Je mehr Sie über wirtschaftliches Kapital verfügen
haben mehr kulturelles Kapital
Sie haben symbolisches Kapital und
desto mehr sind Sie verantwortlich für was
Sie tun, aber wer hat eine
Haftung in Differentialtatsache von a
Leben von Individuen
es bedeutet nicht, dass wir verurteilen sollten
einige Personen mehr als zwei Monate i
glaube überhaupt nicht an Verurteilung und
zum Strafsystem
aber wenn du mich nur wann willst
Ich war ein Kind, es wurde gedacht, dass der Lebensmittelhändler
war der große Bürger unsere Vision
von der Welt, in der sie voreingenommen war, waren sie
unterbrochen von der Welt, in der wir
wurde blockiert, wenn Sie jemand sind
wie Emmanuel Macron, wenn Sie es sind
jemand wie Jacques Chirac
Sie haben Zugang zu der Welt, die Sie können
reisen kann man lesen man kann
Ins Theater gehen kannst du und so
Ihre Wahrnehmung der Welt ist
viel vollständiger
sie ist viel größer
und so, wenn Sie sich dafür entscheiden
etwas Gewalttätiges, wenn Sie
wähle, lass ihn sterben
Migranten und Migranten in der
mediterran emma du bist viel
verantwortungsvoller und es gibt ein System von
Verantwortung Physiotherapeut, der nicht fällig ist
alles das selbe
- ich denke und das für mich werde ich dich
die Geschichte der Klasse zu erzählen ist
die Geschichte meines Körpers, weil ich
stammen aus einem populären Umfeld
heute lebe ich in paris ich schreibe
Bücher, für die ich um die Welt reise
präsentiere meine Bücher und ich fühle mich dabei
mein Körper wie heute ich
bin verantwortungsbewusster als ich war
vorher, weil ich merke
persönlich individuell zu was
mein weltwissen
war in meiner kindheit da eingeschränkt
des Lebens, das uns auferlegt wurde, weil
des Lebens, das meinem Vater auferlegt wird oder
meine mutter und damit ich denke das in
Wirkung, je dominanter Sie sind, desto mehr
Sie haben eine Verantwortung, das ist
wichtig, weil Sie die haben
Gelegenheit, die Welt zu sehen
Sie haben die Möglichkeit, die zu kennen
Welt und so, wenn Sie sich dafür entscheiden
lass Leute sterben und du tust es
wissentlich gemacht und wir
vergiss immer, dass wir immer vergessen, dass wir
Auch die Politik vergisst immer
es ist eine frage von leben oder tod
weil etwas, das sehr ist
bizarr im politischen Bereich ist es
dass die kleinen Leute, die machen
Politiker versucht, die Wahrheit zu verbergen
Politik, während die Wahrheit der
Politik ist Leben oder Sterben
Die Wahrheit der Politik ist, dass wenn
Sie sind Arbeiter in Frankreich, die Sie haben
50% mehr Chance vorher zu sterben
65, wenn Sie schwarz sind, können Sie
von der Polizei getötet werden
wenn Sie ein Kind sind und gbt Sie haben
vier- oder fünfmal wahrscheinlicher
Selbstmord begehen gehören daher zu a
bestimmte Kategorie, die in einer Welt lebt
konkret ist, einem Todesfall ausgesetzt zu sein
verfrüht auf die Tatsache, vor dem zu sterben
andere, die Menschen, die macht
politische Entscheidungen treffen
Gewalttätige haben Blut an ihren Händen
Menschen, die den Tod anderer hervorrufen
Menschen und eine Art Negation von
diese Wahrheit dort und ich will durch
meine Bücher, um sie daran zu erinnern, sie zurückzubringen
diese Realitätspolitik aber unter
die Hymne eines Lebens unter den Mandaten
Markstein
Literatur spielt dort und bei uns keine Rolle
kann sie wahrscheinlich hat mehrere und
Wir können hoffen, dass die Rolle eher
als ein anderer
für mich spielt literatur eine rolle
so entscheidend so viel
wichtig, soweit es gilt
ein diskurs über die welt, wo sie erzählt
etwas über die Welt, wo sie
beteiligt sich an einer Art Diskurs, wo
es kann dem Visionen aufzwingen
Welt der Körper, die es normalerweise nicht sind
dort, wenn du mich willst, habe ich angefangen, ich habe
begann mit a gegen uns zu schreiben
Form der Wut auf die Literatur
dass ich dort sehe, dass ich aus diesem kleinen komme
Dorf in Nordfrankreich für die
aus den genannten gründen gehe ich nach paris
Ich studiere und dort schlage ich Bücher auf und
Ich habe dort sage ich mir, dass niemand darüber spricht
jemand wie meine Mutter dieser jemand
rede über Leute wie meinen Vater
wenn das Rig ein bisschen darüber spricht
Arbeiter hier sind verdiente Arbeiter
Arbeiter bei der Arbeit usw.
sondern die Welt, in der ich aufgewachsen bin
Marx nannte das den Lumpen
Proletariat, das heißt unter dem
Proletariat, das immer noch eine Welt ist
weniger vertreten und ich begann
mit einem Hang der Wut gegen die
Literatur Ich fragte mich, warum die
Literatur handelt nicht von meinem Vater
warum spricht literatur nicht über meine
Mutter und so habe ich eine Form von erreicht
Ich habe versucht, eine Form von zu erreichen
Geste gegen Literatur und Ich
glauben, dass paradoxerweise die Geschichte von
würdige Schriftsteller, die
interessiere mich für Literatur
Leute, die dagegen geschrieben haben
Definition zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt der
Literatur
also ist es dein toni morrison bei orane
Hiller Stone, die auf Schwarze schreiben
aus schwarzer sicht eine zeit wann
niemand tut das und wo, wenn Sie es tun
dass niemand veröffentlicht, sehen Sie
es ist andré gide, der darüber spricht
Homosexualität in einer Zeit, in der sie es ist
absolut unmöglich so
Französischer Literat übrigens er
wirklich irgendwie beleidigt
unwahrscheinlich und für mich die Geschichte der
Literatur
sie hat nämlich was gegen eins
geglaubt, bestand aus einer Art Wut
gegen Literatur
mich, wenn ich, wenn ich unterrichte
Ich unterrichte in den Vereinigten Staaten und wenn ich
siehe meine Schüler
Ich sage immer, sie mochten es nicht wirklich
Literatur ist zu sehr ungesund
Liebesliteratur, die Sie tun werden
Gute Literatur, wenn Sie wütend sind
gegen Literaturen ist es dazu
Ebene dort
andernfalls verschmelzen Sie zu a
Definition von Literatur
und das ist nicht gut mochte nicht zu viel
Libyen hat sich selbst verraten
Grafik Kirin
tatsache wie bei uns geht es h 30 in den mund
Sekunden und Mikko
nein ich denke das hat jeder
Recht, über alles zu sprechen, was ich denke
denke jean paul sartre von den besten
Armut, dass meine Mutter und dass es ist
Dinge, die nicht unbedingt erlebt haben
der eine Rede hält
so nachher ist es wahr, dass, wenn Sie
habe die Dinge gelebt, die es dir bringt a
Art dann eine neue Hauptstadt, die wir
könnte zu allem beitragen, was wir haben
sprach über neue Form des Kapitals, das ist
ein existentielles Kapital ein Kapital von
1 Kapital der Erfahrung, aber es ist
wahr, dass ich hier bin, denke ich, der einzige
Was zählt, ist das Einzige
das zählt, das ist die Frage
die Wahrheit ist, was du sagst
etwas Echtes an den Kisten
beliebt ist, was du sagst
Das Wahre an der seltsamen Art ist dies
dass du etwas Wahres sagst
Schwarze oder Araber in Frankreich und
Dieser Moment zählt, wenn Sie
kannst du ein Mensch sein
homosexuell und halten Reden
Homophobe gibt es tolle Bücher
übrigens drauf und so ist es bei mir
was von Bedeutung ist
nachdem es wahr ist, dass die Autobiographie
Komm schon, ich glaube, sie hat einen
Radikalität, die sehr sehr groß ist und
ist sehr tief wegen a
Irgendwie bist du der Hotelier
Weigerung zwingt Sie, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
die noch mehr als Fiktion geschrieben wird
verhindert, dass Sie entkommen
was ist, wird sein
erzählt und ist in der Tat das sehr
oft die kulturelle Feldliteratur
sind Welten, die nicht dazu dienen
Beobachten Sie die Welt, die früher bezahlt hat
eine Szene, die ich gerne zitiere
gesagt, wer da ist, sind wir oder Jean
luc godard der filmemacher erhält einen caesar
der Ehre in Frankreich bei der Zeremonie von
cesar und jean luc godard sind zu gast bei
Bühne zu gehen und eine Rede zu halten
erhalten seinen Cäsar und wir warten
Godard dankt ihm
die Person, die sein Drehbuch geschrieben hat
Produzent seine Mutter und es ist tatsächlich
Wenn Godard dorthin geht, ist es sehr wichtig
Als Godard dorthin geht, bedankt er sich bei den Frauen
Reinigung bedankt er sich bei den Telefonisten
und die Halle davor
diese Leute, die schön sind
Anzüge mit schönen Kleidern an der
caesar zeremonie bei jean luc
Godard 10 an alle Leute, die dort sind
Raum explodiert vor Lachen Sie sehen, ist ein
Art von dh, wenn Sie
einem Autor oder Produzenten danken
es ist gut und es bewegt
aber wenn du einer Frau dafür dankst
Reinigung ist ein Witz, es ist lustig und
wenn ich mich erinnere, als ich das sah
Szene sagte ich mir aber tatsächlich so
über die Bourgeoisie lachen
dominierende Klassen
es ist wie ein
körperliche Technik, um dem zu entkommen
was Godard sagt
entkommen, was Godard und tut
erzählen
hier sagt er damit die
Kultursystem funktioniert längst
Gewalt
Es gibt Leute, die für sie aufräumen
andere sehen mich, wenn ich autor bin
Ich mache eine Konferenz, zu der ich gehe
Hotel ist jemand, der mein Zimmer putzt
Zimmer im Hotel ist jemand, der
sauber mein Badezimmer ist jemand
wer putzt und so gibt es wenn man will
ein ganzes System, das auch auf basiert
Herrschaftssysteme und wann
Godard sagt, dass alle darüber lachen
ein Weg, nicht zu sehen, was er ist
sagt also mir, wenn ich schreibe
wenn ich literatur mache, sage ich mir
wie man Menschen daran hindert
drehen Sie den Kopf, wie Sie verhindern können
2.2 Menschen weigern sich zu sehen, was ich
erzählt und ich denke, die Autobiographie
September diese Werkzeuge heilige Instrumente
anwendbares Kapital, wenn die Regel ist a
Erbauer, die die Stars waren
auch wünsche charme gesehen haguenets
Instagram-Konto und nicht ich fühle ich mich
Ich sehe eher nach Wut aus, weil
dass ich denke, Wut ist a
Werkzeug zum Verstehen der Welt
sehr mächtig, es ist ein Instrument
erkenntnistheoretisch ein Weg von zwei von
die Welt sehen, die sehr wichtig ist und
Ich erinnere mich daran in meiner Kindheit und
Ich erzähle es insbesondere in der Geschichte von
Gewalt, wenn meine Schwester über sie spricht
über sein Leben sprechen, meine Schwester oder meine Mutter
als sie über ihr Leben sprach sie
sprach von der Armut, die sie hatte
erlebte die Gewalt der Männer, die sie
Beide hatten glücklich darunter gelitten, dass sie
steckten im Dorf fest
die ihre Mutter ihre Großmutter ihre
Urgroßmütter gelebt hatten und
aufgewachsen und als meine Mutter oder meine Schwester
über ihr Leben zu sprechen, das sie beendete
immer ihre Sätze durch, aber das ist ok
Ich habe keine Beschwerden
und wenn Sie wollen, was gemeint ist
dass sie diese Gewalt erlebt hat
sie haben sich reproduziert
und so systematisch
durch Körper durch die Geschichte zu
durch die Generationen durch die
Zeit, dass wir das nicht mehr Gewalt nannten
Gewalt
tatsächlich ist diese Gewalt erschienen
wie normal und es gibt so viele
Gewalt um uns herum, die endet
sie sieht so normal aus
so präsent, dass sie so viel da ist
es reproduziert sich ins Unendliche und daher
Wut ist für mich ein Instrument
Verständnis der Welt, weil
es ist ein Instrument oder gesagt, aber nicht in
tun, dass es nicht normal ist, es ist nicht das
Leben ist nicht Leben, es ist Gewalt
es ist nicht beabsichtigt
sein wer muss so sein und ich ich
Ich wünschte, meine Mutter wäre mehr
Wut, die ich wünschte, mein Vater wäre es
wütender, aber genau das, was sie
gelebt hatte gelebt hatte
so viele Menschen um sie herum, dass wer
tat am Ende mit und
also ich denke ja ich habe das wars
die ich versuche, mit meinen Büchern zu tragen
und das ist es, was ich habe, wenn ich daran zurückdenke
Meine Vergangenheit ist sieben
Es ist diese Wut, weil in der Tat die
Wut sollten wir uns sogar fragen
wenn es nicht sogar mehr als das ist, wenn
es ist nicht einmal ein Instrument
Wissenschaftler in der Tat Pierre Bourdieu
er war ein Mann, der sehr war
Zorn
und deshalb ist er großartig
wissenschaftlich, aber vielleicht ist das das
Sache dort das wissenschaftlichste Kriterium
Das ist der ziemlich interessante Kleber von
Gewölbe auf 59 m
Ich laufe wie Hindi Zahra, da war das
Geschichte von körperlicher Misshandlung und
Moral sagte, geh dorthin, wenn ich divisie ankomme
lass das Ventil diktieren, mach den Tanz
weiß es kennt das Thema des Buches das Buch
ist die Geschichte einer Begegnung
Eines Nachts treffe ich einen Jungen in Paris
auf der Straße um 4 oder 5 Uhr morgens
Rückkehr von einem Weihnachtsessen
mit meinen beiden engsten freunden didier
eribon und geoffroy de lagasnerie für
nicht um nichts vor dir zu verstecken und aber dies
Leute, sie sprechen mich auf der Straße an und und ich
bitte darum, zu mir zu kommen, und ich gebe nach
und wir gehen zu meinem Haus und und wir haben a
Beziehung zusammen machen wir Liebe
mehrmals reden wir miteinander er redet mit mir
von seinem Leben spreche ich über mein Leben und zu einem
Punkt in der Nacht hatte ein
Trinkgeld ist dieser Junge versucht, mir
töten
dagegen verstoßen und deshalb habe ich dieses Buch geschrieben
weil ich das verstehen wollte
was ist passiert warum ist es passiert
so bestanden, dass wir bestanden hatten
einer Form von fast Leidenschaft mit
etwas sehr starkes, das passiert ist
Am Anfang ging eine Form von Leidenschaft zu
die Zerstörung
was ist los in was ist was
was passiert beim kippen der
Gewalt und dann auch das, was ich wollte
es erzählte meine eigene Geschichte
weil ich Lust hatte
Von dem Moment an, in dem diese Geschichte I
lebte, sobald jemand sagen
bei der Polizei, als ich bei der Anzeige erstattete
Ärzte, die mich untersucht haben, meinen Freunden
Ich hatte sofort den Eindruck, dass
diese Geschichte gehörte mir mehr als
andere erzählen es mit anderen
Worte, die nicht mehr was ähnelten
Ich hatte gelebt, als gäbe es eine Lücke
zwischen dem, was ich erlebt hatte, und den Worten
andere über das, was ich erlebt hatte und
Also für mich war es auch eine Form von
die Odyssee jenseits der Wiederaneignung von
die eigene Geschichte und Sie halten
Namyst Aggression stimmte für einen Text davon ab
Menschen und halten Sie zur Rechenschaft
direkt eine Tendenz zu 610 Alpin aus
Karmann- und Gewölbetrakte u
dieser charme der guten sachen und des essens
Vote ja die Schande die sie gemacht hat
Ich bin Teil dieses Prozesses, der in ist
genau macht einen Prozess der Gewalt
Wer war multi, dass sie hatte
offensichtlich nicht, dass es das gab
Schade in dem Moment, in dem ich sehe, dass es gestohlen wird
Etwas
Was ist weniger, was ist mehr für mich
Es ist normal, Dinge zu stehlen, wenn man sie nicht hat
kein Geld, es ist die Gesellschaft, mit der sie
Ihnen ein wenig mehr Geld zu geben als
das müsstest du nicht machen
aber darüber hinaus gibt es natürlich alles
ein Regime männlicher Dominanz
von Homophobie vor sexuellen Übergriffen, die
ist etwas, das LGBT-Menschen
Lebe viel mehr mit Frauen
viel mehr als Männer Männer
gerade und so ist ich wollte
zeigen genau diesen Prozess der
Story Hop mit einem großen h
voll voller Geschichte ist gerade passiert
Kreuz, um diese Geschichte zu produzieren
heftig, um dieses Trinkgeld zu produzieren
aber wie du sagst, es hat es gegeben
auch da war auch die scham und ya
viele Möglichkeiten, dies zu sagen
Geschichte
und ich wollte es damit sagen
Komplexität dort, weil ich mich erinnere
dass, wenn meine Freunde meinen Namen ein wenig gezwungen
eine Beschwerde einreichen, weil es nicht ist
etwas, was ich tun wollte, weil
es ist eine sehr klassische Reaktion
jeder, der angegriffen wurde
Ich wollte diese Geschichte nicht
werde zum Zentrum meines Lebens, lass mich gehen
Wir sprachen immer noch vor Ärzten
noch vor Anwälten noch
verkauft Ich war froh, überlebt zu haben
Ich wollte nicht zurück
diese Geschichte die ganze Zeit meine Freunde
hat mich dazu gedrängt und von der
als ich dem die Geschichte erzählte
Polizei Ich sah, dass die Polizei es versuchte
um daraus einen rassistischen Mythos zu machen
in der Tat zu sagen, ah hier war es ein
Algerischer Junge, deshalb sie
Sie, deshalb sie Sie
Angriff und ich war so vorne
die Polizei und plötzlich ergab ich mich
erwarte, dass mir meine Geschichte gestohlen wird
versuchen, eine rassistische Ideologie zu schaffen
und so habe ich versucht, in der zu finden
liefert eine Möglichkeit, a zu sagen
Bau, wer diejenigen, die wen zerstören
konfrontiere diesen Rassismus, der zerstört
dieser Rassismus und deshalb die Form
das passt zu dem, was du vorher gefragt hast
Die literarische Form hat eine Macht
sehr starke Politik, weil ich habe
entschieden, diese Geschichte zu erzählen
von meiner Schwester in dem Buch das ist mein
Schwester, die mir diese Geschichte erzählt
Ich lebte und wenn sie über die spricht
Gewalt dieses Jungen tat sie sie
hör nicht auf, wird sagen, aber hier ist das
Gewalt dieser Junge stiehlt etwas
Sie sagt, unser großer Bruder fliegt auch
Dinge im Dorf ali dieser Junge
zu griechenland sagte aber leute in diesem
Kleines weißes Dorf im Norden Frankreichs
mich mein Cousin ging ins Gefängnis mein
Opa ist im Gefängnis, ich habe einen Cousin
die im Gefängnis starben
Das Alter von 30 ist also tatsächlich das
Erzählung des Masseurs erlaubt
Rassisieren Sie das Thema Gewalt durch
Tatsache ist, das offensichtlich gut zu zeigen
sicher, dass der Prozess der Gewalt lokalisiert wurde
überhaupt nicht in der Tatsache, dass sie es waren
Algerisch oder nicht, im Grunde hatte ich zwei
zwei Möglichkeiten entweder ich bin ich habe gelogen
Manager und eine Geschichte, die das sagt
es war ein Penny Boys waren ein
Deutsch in dieser Nacht hatte ich
Auf der Straße getroffen und ich lag herum
wer er war oder so fand ich a
literarische Konstruktion das
erlaubt zu zeigen, dass es nicht war
überhaupt das Problem, dass es überhaupt nicht war
alles, was seine ethnische Zugehörigkeit tut und
Also für mich schien es viel zu sein
stärker, viel stärker, das zu tun
und es schien mir sogar, in einen zu fallen
Form von Rassismus zu sagen, weil Sie
sind eine sitzende Person und Sie können
keine Gewalt auszuüben und natürlich
und Menschen, die gewalttätig sind
rassifizierte Gemeinschaften wie in
Gemeinschaften wie unter Weißen
wie gesagt, dass es nur diesen gibt
März sagte nein, es ist ein bisschen mehr
komplizierter als das ich sage ich sage ich
sagen, dass mein, dass mein Körper hatte
Reaktionen jedes Mal, wenn ich sah
jemand, der körperlich ähnlich war
ein Junge nur ich hatte Angst
zum Glück ist es etwas
schnell verblasste Liebe und es war
eher die Reaktion eines Körpers
nur eine intellektuelle reaktion aber aber
so wollte ich das sagen
Geschichte gibt es auch für mich erzählt es und
es war weit über die hinaus
Geben Sie anderen diese Geschichte und ist
also wenn es Anpassungen von gab
beispiel im theater von tomasz ostermeier
in berlin die schaubühne sie für mich
es war sehr dinge
sehr emanzipatorisch, weil plötzlich
es war jemand, der kam, um das zu tragen
Kampfplatz, der gekommen ist, um dies zu tragen
sprechen Sie stattdessen heute an
global gibt es eine bewegung
wenig dagegen gegen nehmen
für jemanden sprechen
sonst erscheint es immer als
Diebstahl als Aneignung absolut
eine kulturelle Aneignung hat es aber nicht
gleichzeitig denke ich, dass wenn
du bist jemand, der gelitten hat
den einen oder anderen Grund hast du nicht
nicht wählen, dieses Leiden zu leben
Sehen Sie, ob Sie als Frau geboren wurden und Sie haben
unter männlicher Dominanz gelitten hast du nicht
nicht gewählt, wenn Sie ein Geek sind
eines Tages überfallen werden, hast du es nicht
gewählt und daher gibt es für mich ein Recht
grundlegend und daher ein Recht
philosophisch und ethisch
Es gibt ein Recht für Einzelpersonen, dies nicht zu tun
ein Leiden ertragen, die nicht haben
ausgewählt
Wir können Einzelpersonen nicht zwingen, sie mitzubringen
ein Leiden, die nicht gewählt haben und
Ich hätte gerne nach der Aggression
ob du gesprochen hättest, wenn ich
hat dir alles gesagt, was sie wollten
Sprich in meinem Namen mit der Polizei, dass sie
wird stattdessen mit dem Richter gesprochen
An dem Tag, an dem der Ort im Kopf ist, wird gesprochen
kopf hamburg
er sagte diese richtung gaza aber immer
scripting oder es waren mehrere Dinge
Zuallererst ja, es ist ein Überlebensmechanismus
nicht noch einmal über diese Geschichte zu sprechen
und wieder und dann hatte sieben
dieses Missverständnis, dass ich welche hatte
war das aus der zeit ge
Diese Geschichte erzählen die Polizisten
Die Polizei hat mir gesagt, hier ist mehr
Ich hatte Spuren an meinem Körper
Ich hatte den Körper zerstört, den ich hatte
Körper in sehr schlechtem Zustand und daher wir
sagte hier, wir haben den Beweis und so wir
schickt sieben Leute für
Jahre im Gefängnis
und ich habe ethisch nicht verstanden und
politisch verstand ich nicht, wie
und warum unbedingt wir verwendet
die Gewalt, für die ich gelebt hatte
Produzieren Sie Gewalt, wenn Sie wollen
denn seine Worte machen mich eingesperrt
Ins Gefängnis gehen Ich sage nicht, dass du musst
nichts tun offensichtlich habe ich nicht
jemand greift dich an und mehr ist es
fertig ist alles in Ordnung und ich sage nicht, dass ich
Hasse diese Person nicht, im Gegenteil
Es ist zweifellos die Person, die ich
Hasse am meisten auf der Welt ohne es ist
zweifle an der Person, für die ich am meisten habe
großer Hass meines ganzen Lebens, den ich hasse
Diese Person wird sie nie wieder von meinem sehen
Leben, aber gleichzeitig verhindert das nicht
dass wir ein kritisches Auge werfen können und
einer der großen und großen Intellektuellen
die großen Intellektuellen, die haben
kritisiert die Art und Weise, in der die Gewalt
Kriminelle arbeiten bei Angela Davis, die
ist beides über Herrschaft geschrieben
männlich ist beides zu kritisieren
Strafvollzug und ich finde das in
In unseren Gesellschaften gibt es das immer
Neigung zur Gewaltproduktion
vor Gewalt, wenn Sie so wollen
und ein viel höheres Niveau
Segelboote, wenn wir das Beispiel von 2.2 der nehmen
Der 11. September ist das, was mit dir passiert
Sehen Sie, es gibt dann natürlich eine Situation
es ist unvergleichlich, aber es gibt eine
Gewaltsituation gibt es einen Angriff
Es gibt Menschen, die sterben, es gibt Blut
da ist feuer was das ist
Was macht die Bush-Regierung?
Die amerikanische Regierung soll gehen
woanders Gewalt erzeugen
woanders des Todes woanders und es ist a
wenig auf diese Weise funktioniert das
Strafvollzug heute ist zu sagen
da jemand Leid verursacht hat, werden wir es tun
ihn leiden lassen
Geschichte der Gewalt, die Shiloh zu
michel foucault foucault
sie sind Teil dessen, was wir könnten
Rufen Sie ein System der Gewalt an
tut und so ist man kann nicht an einen denken
ohne das andere und es fällt mir schwer, das festzustellen
eine Hierarchie zwischen den beiden aber
Auf jeden Fall war genau diese Intuition da
forte von michel foucault, der nur war
da war sowas
Herkunft und Wahrheit in der
Gewalt, die die Polizei als Geschichte bezeichnet
Gewalt wie Michels Bücher
Foucault heißt Geschichte des Wahnsinns
Geschichte der Sexualität ist in der Tat das
was michel foucault sagte war
dass jedes Gebäude
jede Bestätigung, jede Schöpfung
funktioniert immer mit einer Geste von
Urgewalt, also müssen wir
sagt das, wenn Sie die Idee von der erstellen
richtig die idee des coc guito wenn die
Philosophie vor allem Philosophie
Europäische Descartes-Philosophie
schuf die Idee der Vernunft, die es tut
teile den Widerstand mit den Verrückten und allem
Schlag die Narren, die hätte gefeiert werden können
im Mittelalter in einem relativ
mit dem Lärm, der gewesen war
faszinierende Figur zu helfen und das war's
Plötzlich wird der Verrückte rausgeschmissen
des Unternehmens daher ist es erforderlich, dass diese zitiert werden
Satz von Descartes, der sagt, was das ist
sind verrückt und deshalb sagt Foucault zu den
wenn wir die Idee der Vernunft konstruieren
Wir bauen philosophisch
politisch wird die Idee der Vernunft ausgeschlossen
verrückt macht er das gleiche mit dem
dummer Sexualitätsmoment, den wir bauen
die Vorstellung von Sexualität, also von a
Praxis, die Dinge über Sie aussagt
sagt im Moment einiges über dich aus
Psychoanalyse der Staat konstruiert die Idee von
Sexualität findet unter Ausschluss statt
Minderheiten-Sexualitäten mit
Konstruktion der Idee der Perversität
Konstruktion der Idee von
Homosexualität Ihre Prämisse erklärt das
das erste Mal, dass der Begriff verwendet wird
Homosexualität heißt es 1870 71 a
berühmter Artikel namens Artikel
von westphal und so bauen wir die
Homosexuelle Kategorie aus dem Wort und
wir schließen ihn aus
Von dem Moment an, in dem wir das bauen
Kategorie der normalen Sexualität und damit
Wir können deutlich sehen, dass jede Bestätigung
funktioniert unter Ausschluss einiger
Ding und damit dieses Ding, das ausgeschlossen ist
sie kommt, um uns die Wahrheit über was zu sagen
wurde gebaut und das ist was
in der Tat geschieht immer, wenn wir
gebaut frankreich gebaut die idee von
frankreich der französischen nationalität von
Ausweis
es bedeutet die Grenze zwischen Menschen
die Rechte haben, die das Recht haben
leben in diesem Land und andere, die es sind
zum Tode im Mittelmeer verurteilt
Es ist also eigentlich alles Identität drin
gemacht durch einen ursprünglichen Ausschluss und so
es ist eine idee
Ja, vielen Dank, vielen Dank
Danke sehr
[Musik]